I wanted to start with the chatter
that's still out there about Antonio
Brown potentially joining the Seahawks
there was a video recently of Brown
working out with Russell Wilson look
this connection has been out there for a
while now remember last year when the
Seahawks signed Josh Borden the report
was that it was basically going to be
Gordon or Antonio Brown and they went
with Gordon in part because Gordon they
knew they would immediately get on the
field Antonio Brown there was this
lingering sense all of last season that
if anyone's signed him he'd immediately
be put on the Commissioner exempt list
based upon pending investigations for
violation of the personal conduct policy
well here we are now nearly ten months
after the lawsuit originally filed
against Antonio Brown that created the
specter of the Commissioner exempt list
there were two other incidents after
that there was the alleged harassment
via text message of a woman who came
forward to si.com with some details of a
separate incident involving Brown and
then there was the incident earlier this
year with the driver of a moving truck
down in Florida Brown recently pleaded
no contest to felony charges in
connection with that incident so the end
result is if the Seahawks are just
didn't Brown they have no idea when he's
gonna be available nobody knows when
he's gonna be available nobody knows
what kind of a suspension he's going to
get no one knows what the league will do
for the most recent incident and when
you plead no contest you're still going
to get some sort of punishment and my
guest based upon precedent would be four
to six games from that alone and then
there's the incident of harassment what
do they do for that if they determine it
happened and then the big one is the
alleged sexual assault and rape that was
never reduced to a criminal complaint
but was brought and is pending in a
civil proceeding look regardless of
whatever legal standard applies before
the court of Roger Goodell and obviously
it's not beyond a reasonable doubt it's
a lower bar there isn't a middle ground
here either the league is going to
conclude that Brown did it or he didn't
do it so if they believe the alleged
victim when they believe him then we're
likely to find he did it and if they
find that he
mitad sexual assault and/or rape
especially if they find he committed
rape how do I ever let him play in the
NFL again and the thing is it's all
still pending one of the problems I have
with a personal conduct policy there are
no dates there are no deadlines there is
no trigger there is no requirement that
an investigation be completed within 60
days of its commencement it can linger
forever and the Union has no ability to
fight back and that's the way the
personal conduct policy has always been
the people out there that want to dump
on NF OPA executive director - Morris
Smith say well he allowed that to be
created enough it already existed so in
order to change it you have to be
willing to make some other concession
elsewhere that's what these myth
inherited and look I say this all the
time as it relates to the personal
conduct policy how much does every
player want to give up for something
that helps on average two or three
players per year now it potentially
could affect any of them but as a
practical matter it's a very small
fraction of the entire rank and file
that ends up being affected by these
things so how much do you give up to
help an Antonio Brown or the next day
Antonio Brown or the next Antonio Brown
there's a fat one per year now I still
think that the NFL should fix the policy
just as a matter of what is the right
thing to do in a situation like this and
I'll say this the right thing to do
in suspended for 2020 all or part of the
season he should get credit for the 14
games he missed last year because his
posture as relates to the possible
placement of commission or exempt list
kept teams away from signing him plain
and simple he became radioactive he has
served a de-facto 14 game unpaid
suspension since this issue first came
up and since the Patriots cut him after
the second incident the alleged
harassment via text message of the woman
who came forward to si.com once that
came out that's when the Patriots moved
on he was unsigned the rest of the year
unemployed the rest of the year and it's
all because the NFL would never come out
and say yes he'll be on the commissioner
exempt list
no he won't it was the perfect
atmosphere to scare people away from
signing Antonio Brown the end result is
he's missed 14 games period so if he
gets suspended 16 games this year well
he should get credit for 14 even gets
suspended 12 day you can do the math I
can't bottom line is he should get
credit for those games so yes it looks
like the Seahawks are interested but no
there's no clarity as to win he'll be
able to play and yes I believe whatever
happens with the one resolved incident
at least as the criminal courts are
concerned the two other pending
incidents as it relates to the NFL all
of those things whatever the punishment
is he should get credit for the 14 games
that he essentially served last year in
the form of an unpaid suspension
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports